hi guys I wanted to shoot a video on a
great simple test for a knee pain okay
so we have our victim I'm sorry our
patient here that has knee pain and
you've had knee pain for I think you
tummy like about three weeks so it's
been bothering her so I'm gonna show you
what to do okay you might be able to do
this on yourself or you might be able to
find someone to do it on you but I'm
just going to show you how it works so
the first thing is go ahead and stand up
okay and kind of squat down until that
knee hurts okay good okay so have a seat
so I guess it wasn't quite at a 45
degree but it was when she comes down
this is weak okay so what we want to do
is we want to check the flexors on the
leg so there's there's these couple
muscles you have the quadricep femoris
right on both side and then you have a
muscle inside into the hip called the
psoas they're hip flexors they allow the
leg to come up right so first thing I'm
gonna bring this knee as high as you can
okay resist me okay so this one's really
strong okay let's do the same thing
resist me as strong as you can okay it's
weak so this leg is really weak this is
really strong what's gonna happen it's
gonna create a an imbalance it's not
going to be symmetrical so when she
walks this leg is gonna drag a little
bit creating wear and tear on this knee
joint okay so this could have happened
from a fall who knows I mean we're not
going to get into that but I'm just
gonna show you a quick thing to make it
strong and improve the pain okay so if
it's weak on this side we're gonna work
on the opposite side and we're gonna
stimulate this muscle now it's gonna be
really tender in here so just let me
know if it's too much now you could
probably do this with the massage tool
and really get in there and work on the
quadricep on the out don't work on this
side work on the opposite side right
into the hip okay
there's there's about four it's quad
means four you have this muscle here you
got an inside muscle you got the outside
muscle right through in here and you're
just going to massage and really work
out the knots through here it's going to
be very tender
and you can go on the outside to come
right through in here right up into the
hip so this muscle this muscle and this
muscle okay so you work on that so I
just did a tiny little bit make sure you
go all the way up to the hip okay so now
what we're gonna do is we're gonna
recheck this right here bring it up
resist me that's strong okay so now you
might be saying oh I'm not pressing hard
enough well you just do it on yourself
and or have someone do it on you and
you'll see that it will get strong like
that
okay so now I'm gonna have her stand up
and just bend down and see if it's any
better cool great so have a seat here so
that was less pain awesome so it's a
really simple test in quick fix that you
can do on the quadricep always work on
the opposite side so the reason why it
works is both of these are connected on
a circuit the thigh bones connected to
the hip bone right and neurologically
you can work on this side to affect this
side go ahead and try it out and put
your comments down below
hey I appreciate your attention and if
you're enjoying these videos go ahead
and subscribe and I will definitely keep
you updated on future events live events
and webinars that we're going to do very
soon